Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Aiaia! Aiaia!
So Leute, ich bin gerade eine Runde gerannt. Jetzt bin ich am Start. Ich wollte eigentlich ja gestern schon streamen. Das Problem war nur, ich konnte gestern Abend nicht streamen, weil... Warum? Warum konnte ich gestern Abend nicht... Genau, weil ich Backup Restoren wollte auf der Arbeit.
und das Backup-Restoren ist abgebrochen
und dann habe ich bis
19.16 Uhr noch Backup-Restored
und 19.30 Uhr hätte ich eh
off gemusst. Also das
14 Minuten Stream hätte ich jetzt nicht gelohnt.
Es ist kacke, wenn Backup-Restore eigentlich
ohne Probleme durchlaufen sollte und dann
dreimal abbricht.
Keck Wait.
XD HD.
Dann mach mal.
Immer nicht verkehrt.
Ich muss den Backup-Restore, was wir vor einigen Wochen angelegt haben.
Und einmal ist der Container, der den eigentlichen Restore macht, nicht schnell genug ready gewesen.
Das Restore ist abgekackt.
Beim nächsten Mal ist das Ding wahrscheinlich out of memory abgekackt.
Beim dritten Mal habe ich zu schnell gestartet, es ist abgekackt.
Und beim vierten Mal, nachdem ich nochmal alles gelöscht habe, neu gestartet habe, dann ging es.
Ist halt irgendwie kacke, ne?
Um nicht zu sagen, das suckt
Aha, Logitech stellt es am Start
Dann
Mal gucken, ob ich den Knopf treffe
Solange hier die Emotes eingeblendet sind
Deskflow, zack
Fullscreen, Tastatur dran, zack
Einschalten
Ja, weil zum Booten von dem Mini-PC brauche ich ja immer noch meine Tastatur da drin.
Gut, dass ihr keinen Backup-Restore am Freitag macht.
Ne, am Mittwoch haben wir das gemacht.
Ne, warte mal, was ist heute?
Donnerstag, ne?
Ja, ja, am Mittwoch, am Mittwoch.
Mietwoch sage ich jetzt mittlerweile immer.
Weil da so viel gemietet wird.
Der ganze Mittwoch ist Dauergemiete.
Also ich bin echt zufrieden mit meinem Setup hier mit dem Mini-PC auf dem zweiten Desktop
und mit über die Capture Card und Tastatur-Sharing und das ist alles gut.
Das einzig Gute wäre, wenn Wayland mal ihren Shit-Together kriegt und Clipboard ordentlich
funktionieren würde.
Das wäre schon sehr, sehr nice, weil aktuell funktioniert Clipboard-Sharing nur in eine
Richtung und es wäre natürlich viel besser, wenn es in beide
Richtungen funktionieren würde.
Ne, Chat?
Seht ihr auch so, oder?
Natürlich.
Der Chat ist ja high IQ, warum sollte der das anders sehen?
Der
RF-Programmer war gestern, glaube ich,
der hat um 17 Uhr irgendwas
im Chat geschrieben und
ich habe es später erst gelesen, der hat gedacht,
Gibt Stream.
Dem ist ja abends irgendwie immer langweilig.
Was ist das Problem
da dran?
Ach so, weil Sex... Oh, nee.
Ich hab's erst nicht gecheckt,
aber jetzt hab ich's gecheckt, ja.
Eigentlich ist doch Six7 schon wieder voll out, oder?
Irgendwie sagt das schon wieder keiner mehr.
Jetzt, wo es im Mainstream so angekommen ist,
dass sogar die ganzen Boomers das gecheckt haben,
jetzt ist 6-7 aber zumindest bei den
bei den Gen-Alphas
schon wieder out.
Butter mal mein Apfel nebenbei.
Ich habe heute grünes Soßeschnitzel
gefordert, Leute.
Exzellent
Hessische Spezialität
Macht dir nichts draus, Starbucks
Mir geht's ganz genauso
Den Sinn hinter
Six Seven hab ich nie kapiert
Ich glaube, das ist das erste Meme, was
keinen richtigen
Aufhänger so hat, ja?
Sondern wo das
Sagen alleine
genug ist.
Oh Mann.
So.
Ähm, es ist glaube ich zunehmend schwierig
Dass ich die Leute was länger als
Viertelstunde, Viertelstunde ist schon lang
Also das beste Beispiel, was ich mal hatte
Ist
Ich war mal, ich hab beim Friseur gesessen
Und musste noch kurz warten
Da hab ich mir die Leute angeguckt
Und
Da saß dann einer
Wurde gerade gefraziert
Und der Friseur musste gerade irgendwie
Vor an die Kasse, ans Telefon oder irgendwie sowas
Und das hat, keine Ahnung, ohne Scheiß, Leute, wenn es eine Minute gedauert hat,
wenn es eine Minute gedauert hat, wo der Friseur weg war, das war schon viel,
aber das hat er nicht ausgehalten.
Der hat dann unter diesem Tuch, was man immer umkriegt beim Friseur,
hat er sein Handy rausgewurschtelt, TikTok aufgemacht,
sich drei paar Sekunden Shorts angeguckt, dann war der Friseur wieder da.
Der hat diese 45 Sekunden ohne irgendwas nicht ausgehalten.
Das ging nicht.
Was ist denn eine verschlüsselte
VeraCrypt Partition?
Das wird es aber richtig erwarten
Das ist cool, VeraCrypt ist extrem pock
Bei KeyPass brauchst du es jetzt nicht
Weil KeyPass ist ja selbst
Höchstwahrscheinlich
Sicher verschlüsselt
Doppelt hält natürlich besser
Sicherlich nicht verkehrt
Aber VeraCrypt Partition
Schützt dich nicht gegen Keylogger
Das ist klar
Also wenn du jetzt irgendwie irgendein Rootkit oder so eingefangen hast auf deinem Rechner, wo einer alles mitloggen kann, der kann auch warten, bis du dein Save entsperrst und dein Passwort mitschneiden und alles mögliche.
Also da bringt es die Veracrypt-Partition nicht.
Ich finde es aber sehr nice, dass du Veracrypt verwendest, weil für mich ist Veracrypt das Beste, was es so für Verschlüsselungen gibt unter Windows.
Bitlogger kannst du ja komplett knicken, weil da kannst du...
Ich habe es noch nie gemacht, ja.
aber das erste was ich damals über bitlocker gelesen habe ist dass du ein
passwort eine passwort restore funktion hast und ganz ehrlich verschlüsselung
mit passwort restore funktion ohne dass das passwort kennen muss einfach für
nase von dem spreche ich nicht ich spreche vom von meinem friseur also von
dem der milliarde schneidet
Hatte Veracrypt nicht massive Probleme mit Secure Boot?
Das dachte ich auch.
Aber ich habe jetzt Veracrypt Version 1.26.24.
Die ist auch schon relativ alt.
Und bei mir geht Secure Boot ohne Probleme.
First try hat das funktioniert.
Gar kein Ding.
Null Probleme.
Keine Problems.
Oder keine Issues, wie die Armees immer.
zu sagen.
Wie sieht man Vera Crip nicht?
Wird Vera Crip
nicht gecaptured, wenn ich das zeige?
Warte mal. Vorschau.
Tatsächlich!
Vera Crip wird nicht gecaptured!
Moment,
Moment, Moment. Seht ihr Keypass?
Wenn ich Keypass aufmache.
Seht ihr das?
Das seht ihr auch nicht,
lul okay das ist ja sogar mal irgendwie eine sinnvolle funktion ich wäre natürlich
ich werde das natürlich nice wenn man das ausschalten kann aber ich meine dass das windows
was wurde noch mal vor wer akrib genutzt rupt trug kripp ist der vorgänger von vera krypt
Genau
Truecrupt, genau, Truecrupt war das
So, erstmal eine Runde Fische
So, ich muss mal kurz
Leute, ich hab jetzt in drei Minuten
Hab ich Bereitschaft
Rufbereitschaft von
Jetzt in zwei Minuten
bis dienstag 8 uhr war kurz vor acht bis kurz vor
das ist das ist fast infinite money klitsch ja es wird wahrscheinlich nichts
sein wenn was ist habe ich natürlich gelitten und das gibt massive kohle
aller aber wir haben halt auch nicht einfach nur rufbereitschaft mit aja wenn
du dran gehst, ist gut. Ne, du musst dran
gehen und du musst innerhalb von, ich
glaube, einer Stunde
musst du ready sein.
Du hast eine Reaktionszeit von einer Stunde.
Das heißt, wenn du irgendwie unterwegs bist,
musst du zackig heimflitzen, Rechner anmachen,
einloggen.
Wie oft gibt es mal eine Notfahrt? Ach, das
ist selten.
Das ist selten. Also ich
hatte schon ein paar Alarmierungen,
auch nachts.
das war dann aber meistens nur kleinkram also so einen richtigen notfall wo wirklich viel
wo dann auch wirklich vieles kaputt war kann ich mich jetzt in drei jahren an eine sache erinnern
notebook im rucksack du meinst dass man dann über ein handy hotspot reingeht das würde
tatsächlich funktionieren ja das würde funktionieren bei der gelegenheit würde
ich vielleicht noch ein Headset mitnehmen?
Es kann sein. Es kann jederzeit
sein.
Ja, es ist halt so.
Irgendjemand, Leute, ich hab
6-7 Zuschauer.
Da hat sich halt mal jemand hingesetzt.
Management-technisch.
Und hat ausgerechnet,
wenn irgendwelche
wichtigen Systeme down sind,
dann kostet
uns das auch am Wochenende
was weiß ich
eine Million pro Stunde
oder so, ich sag jetzt einfach irgendwas
ich hab keine Ahnung
eine Million pro Stunde
und da haben sie sich überlegt, okay
wenn wir da irgendeinen Admin-Dude
hinsetzen daheim und den bezahlen
und selbst wenn in 10 Jahren
nur einmal was ist
und es halt schneller gefixt ist
hat es sich immer noch gelohnt
da steckt halt Geld dahinter
Genau, wir müssen
Da wäre ich natürlich auch dafür
Dass die Million dann nicht
Strafe bezahlt wird oder irgendwie sowas
Oder ausfallmäßig
Bezahlt wird, sondern wenn wir den Ausfall
Fixen, kriegen wir quasi
Ist aufgerundet bis zur nächsten Stunde oder so
Das wäre nice, ey da würden sich aber alle
richtig kloppen um die Rufbereitschaft.
Und dann
werden die Anreize auch vielleicht ein bisschen
falsch gesetzt, weil ich sehe
schon kommen, dann würden die Leute
explizit irgendwelchen
Mist einbauen, der automatisch während
ihrer Rufbereitschaft läuft, dass es ausfällt,
dass sie es dann fixen können
und die Millionen kassieren.
Beide hat er lange für die Sub.
Für den Sub.
Wir kriegen...
Wir kriegen Bonus
für Systemverfügbarkeit.
Ich glaube, das geht irgendwie so.
Also,
über...
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wie das ist.
Wenn die Systemverfügbarkeit größer als 80% ist,
kriegst du quasi für jeden weiteren bis 100%
kriegst du einen Multiplayer für deine Bonuszahlung.
Und das kann schon einiges ausmachen an Kohle.
Also wir reden jetzt natürlich nicht im Millionenbereich, ja.
Wir reden hier von, was weiß ich,
ein paar Hundert, 1000 Euro vielleicht so irgendwie.
2000 Euro.
Ja, aber das ist eigentlich ganz gut.
Im Umkehrschluss,
im Umkehrschluss,
es gibt bei uns so ein
automatisches System,
was Verstöße
gegen Vorgaben auf Servern erkennt.
Ja, also bei uns gibt es
beispielsweise eine Vorgabe,
ich denke mir jetzt mal irgendwas aus,
ja, ich weiß sogar was.
Wenn Grafana
an InfluxDB
angebunden wird, muss das über
HTTPS abgesichert sein, die Verbindung.
So, da gibt es so eine
Vorgabe und da gibt es auch im Hintergrund
irgendeine Software, die das checkt.
Die guckt dann, ist Grafana installiert,
wenn Grafana installiert ist, ist InfluxDB
installiert, äh, konfiguriert
und wenn InfluxDB konfiguriert ist, ist HTTPS.
Die guckt da wirklich nach und wenn dann
was gefunden wird, was nicht
der Vorgabe entspricht,
dann
geht ein Ticket auf und du hast
30 tage zeit das ticket zu bearbeiten wenn das innerhalb von 30 tagen nicht bearbeitet also
nicht erfolgreich geschlossen wurde also wenn wenn der fehler wenn du wenn du quasi dieser scanner
nicht mehr anschlägt wenn der scanner weiterhin anschlägt so nach 30 tagen geht das wird das
direkt eskaliert an deinen chef und dann weitere 30 tage wird es direkt am abteilungsleiter eskaliert
und danach direkt an den IT-Chef.
Moin, AF-Programmer.
Ich habe dich gestern im Chat gesehen, aber ich konnte gestern Abend nicht mehr.
Ich muss gestern Abend noch Backup
restoren bis 19.16 Uhr.
So, und wenn
diese Eskalationsstufe erreicht ist
von deinem Chef zum
Abteilungsleiter, dann kriegst du
automatisch 10% Bonus abgezogen.
Und das Schlimme ist,
wahrscheinlich, weil ich es nicht direkt
zuordnen könne, das Schlimme ist,
nicht nur du kriegst
10% abgezogen. Das gesamte
Team kriegt 10%
abgezogen.
Kollektivstrafe.
Also wenn du es verkackst,
kriegt dein gesamtes Team 10% Bonus
weniger.
Das ist natürlich nicht sonderlich beliebt, kann man sich vorstellen.
Klar machen wir das alle für Kohle.
Umsonst geht ja keiner schaffen.
Also, außer Leute, die ehrenamtlich was machen oder so.
Aber die müssen ja auch irgendwo ihre Kohle verdienen.
Ich mach mal kurz Pac-Man Update.
In der Zeit wollte ich mal aufs Handy gucken, weil...
Ich spiele mir ein.
Ich hatte irgendein cooles Video letztens auf dem Handy an.
Das wollte ich mit euch gucken.
Was könnte es denn gewesen sein?
Äh, Theo wollte ich mit euch bestimmt nicht gucken
Ähm
Dass Ubuntu wieder irgendwas auf Rust umstellt
Wollte ich mit euch auch nicht gucken
Irgendwelche D&D Lore Videos
Wollte ich mit euch auch garantiert nicht gucken
Wo ist das denn, was wollte ich denn mit euch gucken
Irgendwas wollte ich mit euch gucken
Ah hier, das habe ich nicht
Also ich habe nur den Anfang durchgescrollt.
Keine Ahnung, ob das Video was taugt.
Zumindest kann ich mich darüber auslassen.
Okay, den können wir auch gucken.
Den gucke ich auch immer gerne.
Linux-Distro, da fand ich den Titel ganz gut.
Tierlist.
Mal gucken, ob ich zustimme.
Hier, das da. Keine Ahnung, ob das was taugt.
Und ich muss Chatterino anmachen.
Gothgirl-Shorts.
Ja, bei den Shorts check ich nicht, was da abgeht.
Die Shorts-Empfehlungen sind etwas weirdchamp oftmals.
Achso, ein Fire-Ship wollte ich gucken mit euch.
Der hat nämlich ein Video zum Axios-Hack gemacht.
Oder zum Axios-Supply-Chain-Angriff.
War da jemand von euch betroffen?
Ich meine, wir dürfen nicht vergessen, über 100, haben wir gestern gesehen,
über 100 Millionen...
JavaScript-Developer.
Über 100 Millionen Downloads in der Woche.
Nein, natürlich nicht die betroffene Version.
Betroffen ist irgendwie Axios 1.14, glaube ich, und 0.36.
War jemand von euch von dem Axios?
Oder vielleicht weiß er es noch gar nicht.
Benutzt jemand Axios in seinen Frontend oder Node.js Backend Software?
Axios wurde Supply Chain Hackermand.
Cloud Code?
Ja, da ein bisschen Schadenfreude habe ich da schon.
Shortblocker.
Schau dir das Bild an.
Okay, Moment, RF-Programmer.
Ich mache mal kurz Discord auf und gucke rein.
Hast du Katzen...
Das sind aber keine Katzenbilder, oder?
Was ist das?
Äh?
Axios war es so, Axios hat, wir gucken uns kein rechtliches Fire-Ship-Video an, Axios hat eine neue Dependency eingeführt, die in der Versionsumme glaube ich 420 hatte oder sowas, da weißt du auch schon, was Sache ist.
Irgendwas, was unauffällig klingt, irgendwas Java, Crypto, JS oder sowas, als Dependency eingeführt und dieses Paket wiederum hat dann Malware nachgeladen.
Malware.
Okay, schauen wir mal kurz.
Stream-Ankündigungen.
Nein.
Cute Chat.
Ach ja.
Hehe.
Ganz viele Katzis.
Die sind niedlich hier.
Ein Bild zeige ich dir mal hier vom AF-Programmer.
aus
aus dem Discord
mit erstmal so wie sich das gehört schön am Arsch
gerochen
aber die sind niedlich die zwei
hab ich euch schon gezeigt heute morgen war die Katz
wieder da.
So saß sie bei mir
in der Küche und wollte was zu futtern
haben.
Also, muss ich sagen, das ist nicht
By the way, das ist nicht meine Katze, ne?
Die besucht mich seit
zwei Wochen oder sowas.
Besucht die mich regelmäßig.
Und mittlerweile
ist sie schon der Meinung, die ganze Küche
gehört ihr.
Die, die, die
Ja.
Das ist jetzt ihre Küche und die fragt sich, was sitzt du so doof rum?
Gib mir lieber was.
Ich bin jetzt das Haustier, ja.
Das fand ich übrigens sehr gut, die Antwort.
Ich hab hier geschrieben, da sitzt was Dickes in meiner Küche.
Und da hat einer drauf geantwortet, das sind die Gedanken der Katze.
Und genau das kann ich mir vorstellen, denkt sich die Katze gerade.
Was sitzt der dicke Typ da so rum?
Der soll mir lieber mal was zu fressen geben.
Guck schon ein bisschen vorwurfsvoll, oder?
Warum dauert das denn hier so lang?
Das war auch schon mal besser
Bin ich doch schon
Hab ich eigentlich geupdatet?
Ja, machen wir hier noch Our Packages
Jetbrains Toolbox
Check for updates
Excellent
Oh, die haben ja immer mehr zu
Ach ne, Quatsch, ich bin ja hier gar nicht eingeloggt
Mit meiner Subscription
Du bist jetzt in Istanbul, noch mehr Katzen hier
Hab ich dich auch mal gefragt, was du da eigentlich machst?
Irgendwas, irgendwas
Computermäßiges oder was
Also falls du es verraten willst, ne
Wenn nicht, muss jetzt hier nichts leaken
Im Chat
Moment, ich will mal eine Pille nehmen
Auf Crash
Warum nicht, 1 vs 1 auf Rust
Das kann durchaus sein, dass sie noch woanders hingeht
Und sich füttern lässt, ach Urlaub
Ich hab gedacht, du bist von der Arbeit da
End of JS
Ich kann mir
Ich finde den Content ja prinzipiell
Vom, wie heißt der, Primogen oder so
Spricht man den aus, glaube ich
An sich nicht schlecht
Ich komme mit der Art nicht klar
Der ist mir einfach zu
Zu aufgedreht
Und
Und, und...
Irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, ich kann es mir nicht angucken.
An sich ist es eigentlich Content, der mir gefallen müsste, aber ich kann es mir nicht angucken.
Das ist mir zu anstrengend.
Ich wollte, das wollte ich gerade sagen, guck mal.
Eigentlich sagt man ja immer, erster Security-Tipp, Packages up to date halten.
aber packages up to date halten ist auch der beste weg um direkt gehackt zu werden
ja die paar videos die schwanger guckt hat dass ich kommt kommt mir sagen
kopf hier ist besser ich kann mich immer noch entscheiden black ops 1 oder kot 4
was mir am besten gefallen hat kann ich nicht sagen war aber beides sehr
danach habe ich immer weniger gespielt als black ops 2 habe ich noch viel gespielt mw3
habe ich noch viel gespürt das alte mw3
das war früher oder war das nicht sogar noch früher 2008 genau genau wollte gerade sagen
chat wir dürfen nicht vergessen die xbox 360
die kam 2005 glaube ich raus hier
2005 und man muss sich mal angucken die xbox 360 die hatte richtig brutal gute
Hardware zu release. Guck mal,
ein Triple Core. Triple Core
3,2 GHz Power
PC. Das Ding hatte
sowas von Wumms
für die damalige Zeit. Ich meine, wir reden hier von
2005.
Also gefühlt, ich kann das jetzt nicht untermauern,
aber gefühlt
war die Xbox 360
und die PS3, wobei es bei der
PS3 von der Architektur her schwieriger war,
das waren die stärksten Konsolen
für ihre Zeit, die es je gegeben hat.
aus meiner Sicht, ich kann es nicht beweisen,
dass es so ist, ja,
aber mein Eindruck war,
dass damals die Dinger besser waren,
als die allermeisten
High-End-PCs,
du musstest, also,
dreifach Core-CPU
hat damals praktisch
niemand gehabt, ja,
ähm,
wobei, das muss man ein bisschen relativieren,
bei der Xbox 360,
bei der Xbox 360 war es ja so,
Zwei Cores waren für die Spiele und ein Core war erstmal für das User Interface und das Overlay und den Voice Chat und sonst was.
Wobei ich glaube, man konnte das, je nach Game, das konnte unterschiedlich aufgeteilt werden.
Also für mich, ich muss auch sagen, für mich war auch Xbox Live auf der Xbox 360 Peak.
mit den
Avataren, mit dem Gamerscore,
das alles in allem war einfach super.
Aber ganz ehrlich,
ich glaube, also
Hardware, Leistungstechnik
und vor allem für den Preis
war das die stärkste Konsole
mit der PS3, die Siegegema.
Ich meine, wir dürfen nicht vergessen,
die PS3, es gab ja ein paar
Supercomputer mit PS3, damals.
Wahrscheinlich keine in der Top 10.
Ja?
Ja, aber... Ja, genau!
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Gab's... Also das war nicht ohne.
Das war richtig...
Für ihre Zeit waren die richtig brutal gut.
Ich finde auch, das waren die letzten
Konsolen mit richtig Innovation.
Xbox One, PS4,
das war im Endeffekt ein verkappter
Mittelrange-PC.
und danach auch, ja.
Und, was ich immer witzig finde,
Chad, wisst ihr aus dem Kopf, wie viel RAM
die Xbox 360 hatte?
Weißt du, ich könnte sagen,
512 hat die, glaube ich,
gehabt, RAM.
Was, sieht man das irgendwie? Memory?
Ja, 512.
Und guckt mal,
wie krass die Sachen
eigentlich damals waren,
die mit 512 MB RAM gelaufen sind.
So wenig, ja, ja, ja.
Das ist mega, wenn man sich das mal überlegt.
GTA 5 kam auf der Konsole zuerst raus.
GTA 5 Release war noch auf der Xbox 360.
Und PS3.
Und danach kam es dann auch für die anderen Konsolen noch.
Aber das war schon krass.
Und was mir heute wieder aufgefallen ist, Leute.
Ich habe heute auf einer Produktionskiste, habe ich was per Helmchart, also von einer Produktionskiste, habe ich per Helmchart was in einem Kubernetes Cluster installiert.
Dazu muss man, dazu macht man Helm, ich weiß gar nicht was, Repo Refresh oder irgendwie sowas.
Ich weiß es gerade nicht mehr aus dem Kopf.
Und das war eine kleine VM, auf der ich das ausgeführt habe.
Die 4M hatte nur 2 GB RAM oder sowas.
Ja, normalerweise würde man davon ausgehen, das reicht.
Aber ne, allein schon ein Helm Repo-Refresh braucht über 1 GB.
Über 1 GB.
Nur für den Repo-Refresh.
Und auf der Xbox 360 liefen mit 512 MB RAM das komplette Betriebssystem mit Voice-Chat und allem.
Und die Games.
The fuck?
und ein Super Nintendo ist im Prinzip schlechter als ein Taschenrechner gewesen.
Ah, also das war ja so die Konsole meiner Kindheit, Super Nintendo und N64
und also man kann das noch nicht mal vergleichen.
Jede wirklich billigste AliExpress Fitness Uhr ist um Welten schneller als ein Super Nintendo oder ein N64.
Die meisten poplichen, super billigen Low End Micro Controller sind um Größenordnungen schneller als ein Super Nintendo.
Oder auch als ein N64.
also das ist wahnsinn wenn man sich überlegt was damals alles darauf
gelaufen ist oder umgedreht könnte man sagen ganz schön abgedreht dass man
heute für den helm repo refresh oder repo update oder helm update repo ich
weiß nicht wie der befehl genau ist über den gk ram brauche ich muss mal kurz hier
die night mode ausmachen sonst penn ich ein
Naja, das
finde ich stimmt nicht.
Die
Hardware, nein, du hast nicht
Unrecht, aber ich sag mal, die Hardware stagniert
ja so ein bisschen. Also,
die Riesensprünge in der Hardware
bleiben ja schon lange aus.
Wie gesagt, ich hab einen
High-End-Rechner gekauft, 2022
und jetzt ist es 2026.
Das Ding ist immer noch High-End.
Dreieinhalb Jahre. Das ist der Witz.
Früher musstest du dir nach eineinhalb Jahren einen Rechner kaufen,
weil gar nichts mehr drauf lief.
Und jetzt habe ich einen High-End-Rechner gekauft,
nach dreieinhalb Jahren ist es immer noch High-End.
Also das ist schon krass.
Dazu kommt aber,
das finde ich mittlerweile,
die Games halt einfach nur grottig laufen.
Also viele, viele Games.
Guckt euch mal das Desaster an,
was am Anfang bei Borderlands 4 war.
Das Game ist ja teilweise auf den krassesten Rechner
nicht über 60 FPS gekommen.
Oder unter, unter 60 FPS.
Ja, Ubisoft traue ich das denen.
Na gut, also eins ist schon mal klar.
Wenn Ubisoft ein Spiel vibe-coded,
eins, was erhalten bleibt, ist,
du musst auf jeden Fall Türme einnehmen.
Weil es ist tatsächlich egal,
ob das Assassin's Creed ist oder Far Cry
oder was auch immer da ist.
Du musstest in allen Ubisoft-Spielen Türme einnehmen.
Immer Türme einnehmen.
Und ich meine, GTA 5, also man muss ja auch mal ehrlich sagen,
es ist ein Wunder,
dass die GTA 5
und auch Battlefield 3 damals
überhaupt gescheit lauffähig
gekriegt haben auf der xbox 360 ja aber die mussten schon einige abstriche
machen also war battlefield 3 auf dem pc damals verglichen hat mit xbox 360 das
waren schon ziemlich großen unterschied ja also nicht nur von der auflösung auch
von den frame raten von von der sicht und von den details und es war schon
echt ein großer unterschied
ist das wirklich so dass cs2 schlecht läuft sie erst hat doch immer so den den ruf dass
es auf jedem toaster läuft ist es bei cs2 nicht mehr so
gpt 5.4 keine semper das konnten die alten gps wahrscheinlich auch schon wie gut das ist muss
müsste man ja mal überprüfen.
Das Problem ist, ich kann es nicht überprüfen,
weil ich selbst keine Ahnung habe von Assembler-Programmieren.
Also wir haben mal im Stream,
vielleicht erinnert sich noch einer dran,
wir haben mal zwei Streams gemacht,
da haben wir den Ultra-Low-Power-Prozessor
vom ESP32
mit Assembler versucht,
was beizubringen.
Das hat auch ganz gut funktioniert,
aber ich würde nicht sagen, dass ich dadurch
irgendeine Ahnung von Assembler hätte.
Also ich bin ja gar kein Fan von dem neuen DLSS oder DSSL?
Nee, DLSS heißt, ne?
Super Sampling, bla.
Die Geschichte, wo sie Werbung mitgemacht haben per KI,
die Gesichter zu generieren und sowas.
Das finde ich richtig dämlich.
Das hat nichts...
Also ich bin der Meinung, Hersteller...
Also, ob es dann immer noch so sein wird, sei mal dahingestellt.
Aber die Hersteller machen sich ja schon Gedanken,
dass ihr Spiel nach Möglichkeit
so eine gewisse
gewissen
Ausdruck hat, ja
ein gewisses
Design
das so ein bisschen aus einem Guss
zusammenpassend ist, vom Menü bis zur
Schriftart, von den
Umrissen der Figuren, von den
Texturen, von den Models, von allem
das muss ein Gesamtbild ergeben
und wenn dann einfach Gesichter per KI
drüber gerendert werden
also
das finde ich ziemlich für den Arsch
und ich muss auch sagen
die Sachen die ich da gesehen haben
da hat mir das Original
besser gefallen, das hat einfach viel
viel besser in dieses Gesamtbild
von dem Game gepasst als das mit den
abscalten Gesichtern
übrigens weiß ich ganz
cool, weil du gerade sagst CS, CS GO
ähm, CS 2
basiert ja höchstwahrscheinlich
denke ich mal auf der neuen Source Engine
Da gibt es jetzt einen neuen Bau dir dein PC Game Baukasten.
S-Box.
Hat das schon mal jemand gesehen?
Das ist von dem Gary Smott Typ.
Und die haben jetzt einen Deal.
Also warum ich das überhaupt gesehen habe.
Ihr wisst, ich bin überhaupt kein Spieleentwickler.
Überhaupt.
Aber ich glaube, Gary Smott hat jeder zumindest schon mal gehört.
Ich bin überhaupt, Spieleentwicklung interessiert mich persönlich null.
Aber was ich da ganz cool fand.
Und deswegen habe ich das auch gefunden. Die haben jetzt einen Deal mit Valve geschlossen, dass Spiele, die mit diesem Baukasten programmiert werden, als Standalone-Titel auf Steam veröffentlicht werden können.
Ohne, dass du Gebühren für die Engine bezahlen musst. Das ist eigentlich mega nice.
Ich meine, über Steam veröffentlichen und Gewinnbeteiligung für Valve und so, das gibt es natürlich immer noch.
Aber das könnte vielleicht durchaus die eine oder andere Alternative sein.
Und das ist nicht mehr so wie Garrys Mod, dass du das nur quasi in Engine bauen kannst.
Du hast hier auch wirklich so einen Visual Editing Modus und du kannst mit C Sharp neue Funktionalität implementieren und sowas.
fand ich eigentlich richtig cool.
Ich werde es mir nicht angucken. Wie gesagt, ich interessiere mich null für
Spieleentwicklung. Aber
der Deal mit Valve, dass du die Sachen
auch Standalone auf Steam veröffentlichen kannst,
das fand ich halt cool.
Wann kommt Half-Life 3?
Angeblich
bald. Es war ja die letzten
Monate wieder ordentlich,
ordentlich
ähm
wie heißt
Gerüchte? Ich wollte sagen
Rumors, Alter. Gerüchte.
Ob da diesmal was dran ist?
Ja, keine Ahnung
Aber Half-Life 3
Wär schon enorm
Ja, aber die letzten Monate gab's wieder
Viele Gerüchte um Half-Life 3
Also ich würd mich ja richtig freuen
Das könnt ihr euch vorstellen
Ich bin der übelste Half-Life Fanboy
Ich würd mich richtig freuen über Half-Life 3
und ich glaube auch, die werden das nicht verkacken
ihr wisst, ich bin mittlerweile echt skeptisch
was sowas angeht, aber ich glaube nicht, dass
ihr Half-Life, also das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass Valve Half-Life 3
verkackt
die bringen ja so gut wie nix raus und wenn sie was rausbringen
ist das meistens gut
ja, die haben auch ein paar mal ins Klo gegriffen
zum Beispiel
mit ihrem Dota-Kartenspiel
und ich weiß gar nicht mehr
wie es, Architekt hieß das glaube ich, gell
und was mit ihrem komischen
Hero-Shooter da ist, ich hab den Namen schon
wieder vergessen. Bin ich mir auch nicht sicher,
ob das was wird oder geworden ist.
Die haben ja auch so einen Hero-Shooter-Beta
rausgebracht von...
Deadlock hieß das, gell?
Genau. Weiß ich nicht, wie
beliebt das ist oder werden wird.
Kein Schimmer.
Hast du mal
Black Mesa gespielt? Wir haben das sogar im Stream
zusammen durchgespielt.
Bilde ich mir ein. Wir haben
Black Mesa im Stream zusammen durchgespielt und
wir haben Half-Life 1 zusammen
im stream durchgespielt wir haben wir haben es glaube ich sogar zweimal durchgespielt im stream
einmal als es auf steam rausgekommen ist und noch mal als xen dazu gekommen ist ich habe wenige
spiele so oft durchgespielt ja vielleicht zwei nicht so oft ich bevorzuge tatsächlich half life
1, was aber
halt auch daran liegt, dass es das erste Half-Life
für mich war und ich das erste
geile Shooter-Game so auf dem
neuen Rechner und so. Ja, ich bevorzuge
Half-Life 1.
Für mich
die schönste Art, Half-Life 1 zu
spielen, ist tatsächlich
M-Mod
auf Steam.
Das ist quasi Original
Half-Life mit ein paar kleinen Verbesserungen
dabei und
Software Rendering, also so wie Half-Life 1
eigentlich aussehen sollte,
oder aussehen soll,
ist für mich die einfachste Variante und beste Variante
Half-Life 1 zu enjoyen.
Also ich glaube,
ich habe kein anderes Spiel so oft durchgespielt
wie Half-Life 1.
Es wäre möglich,
dass ich Secret of Mana,
das erste,
Secret of Mana,
dass ich das vielleicht ähnlich oft durchgespielt habe wie Half-Life 1.
Aber das glaube ich nicht.
Half-Life 1 habe ich bestimmt über 20 Mal durchgespielt.
Das kenne ich, das habe ich gesehen.
Da gibt es sogar schon eine Demo.
Genau, das kenne ich.
Jetzt fehlt eigentlich nur noch, dass eine Opposing Force remaked.
Das würde ich persönlich mehr feiern als Blue Shift.
Aber vielleicht ist es schwierig, Opposing Force zu remaken, weil es ja von Gearbox kam.
Ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt gar nicht sicher, wer hat denn eigentlich Half-Life Blue Shift entwickelt?
War das auch Gearbox?
Ja, wir hatten das entwickelt.
Sieht man das hier?
Gearbox, ah, ist auch von Gearbox.
Ja, dann soll es kein Problem sein.
Das habe ich auch oft durchgespielt
Aber nicht 20 mal
A Link to the Past habe ich vielleicht 5 mal durchgespielt
Oder so
Die mussten fast die Mondmission abbrechen
Wegen Outlook
Moment das war ernst gemeint
Ich dachte das war ein Witz
Das war doch bestimmt ein April-Scherz, oder?
Kann ich mir sonst nicht vorstellen
Was brauchen die Outlook
Was brauchen die Outlook in der Mondmission
Die sollen Linux mit MUT verwenden
CLI E-Mails Only
Kennt ihr MUT?
das ist für boomer also für hardcore linux boomer enjoyer
textbased e mail client und ziemlich die ekligste art und weise wie man e mails lesen kann
das war echt die mussten moment zeigt mal wo ist sein tweet
ja das da meinst du oder von wann wurde das gepostet
right now the austria astronauts are calling houston because the computer on a spaceship das
ist das ding von davon spacex oder ist running to instance of microsoft outlook and they can't
figure out why das ist doch die welt das ist doch die welt das kann das kann es
sein die politiker wenn doch die verwenden
doch kein outlook im aber ich finde es cool dass die nasa sich in sich ein
rdp in kann anscheinend wenn das windows ist ach du scheiße alter hat microsoft
war wieder zu viel geweib coded
läuft dazu können wir nur sagen
Ich kann zu SNMP per netcatch noch was witziges erzählen und zwar von der Arbeit.
Also bei uns auf der Arbeit ist es so, weil es gibt ja in Deutschland gesetzliche Regulatorik,
die besonders Versicherungen und Banken betrifft.
Banken haben es dann noch schlimmer.
Aber uns ist es so,
wenn ich mich auf einen Server
verbinde per SSH,
dann kann ich nicht einfach sagen,
ähm, kann ich nicht einfach sagen,
SSH, äh,
Prot Server A,
äh, oder, oder hier,
oder, oder, also das hier geht schon mal gar nicht.
Geroot-Ad, ne, das ist ja klar.
Das geht schon mal gar nicht.
Das geht schon mal gar nicht. Aber ich kann auch nicht so
machen und, und dann, und dann
sudon ja das geht nicht so was ich machen muss ist ich wollte ich tipps
jetzt mal so ungefähr ich muss mich verbinden gegen ein ssh proxy aus zum
teufel macht meine tastatur meine maus hier ich muss mich verbinden gegen den
ssh proxy und als user muss ich dann angeben wo ich hin will das ist so ganz
ganz weird, so ungefähr sieht das dann aus.
Ne, ist das nicht ssh-u-l
ist das, ne? Genau.
So, also ich muss mich quasi mit
diesem Login einloggen auf diesem ssh-Proxy
und
der leitet mich dann
auf den Zielserver weiter.
Der Sinn ist,
dass die alles mitschneiden können.
Die machen man in the middle.
Diese ssh-Proxy zeichnet jede ssh-Session
auf. Und wenn dort einer irgendwas
anstellt und
irgendeine Behörde gucken will,
was hat er denn gemacht, können sie in den Logs nachgucken
und die aufgezeichnete SSH-Session sich angucken.
So.
So läuft das.
So läuft das bei uns.
So, und jetzt gibt es ein Problem.
Wie macht die SCP?
Wie macht die SCP mit sowas?
Wenn ich, also ich muss das anders erzählen,
wenn ich mich einlogge,
so hier per SSH-Proxy,
Dann kriege ich jetzt vom SSH-Proxy eine Ausgabe.
AD-Kennung muss ich dann eingeben.
AD-Passwort muss ich dann nochmal eingeben.
Das wird alles interaktiv abgefragt.
Dann 2-Faktor-Authentifizierung vom Handy muss ich eingeben.
Und dann Login-Grund.
Die drei Sachen muss ich nochmal eingeben.
Das heißt, per SSH, da ist so ein interaktives Terminal-Input erforderlich.
So, mach das mal mit SCP.
SCP, da geht das nicht mit interaktivem Terminal-Input, so ohne weiteres.
So, bisher war es so.
Ja, erstens ist es das Gleiche, ne?
Aber es ist ähnlich.
So, nächstes Problem ist, jetzt müssen wir irgendwas kopieren.
Ist Login-Grund ein Freitextfeld?
Login-Grund ist ein Freitextfeld, ja, aber du musst beim Login-Grund, zumindest für Produktion, musst du was Gültiges eingeben.
Das kann zum Beispiel ein gültiges Incident-Ticket sein.
Versicherung, nicht Bank.
und der checkt dann auch beim login im hintergrund ob es dieses ticket gibt und ob dieses ticket mit
dem service beziehungsweise ob der server zu dem service gehört mit dem das ticket verknüpft ist
ja das ist sehr also wild wird wild kontrolliert alles so und jetzt hat die sache scp geht nicht
so ohne weiteres.
Bisher war das so,
du musstest diese Login-
Zeremonie hier, am Tag
musstest du das zweimal machen
und dann wurde zumindest die ganze
Sache mit, bis auf die Reason,
bis auf den Login-Grund wurde gecached.
Und damit ging SCP,
weil nichts mehr nachgefragt
wurde. Ja, der Proxy ist so
schlau, wenn eine SCP-Anfrage kommt,
will er keine Reason haben und das geht.
Jetzt sind sie aber in ihrer Weisheit
auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen,
und haben dieses Caching ausgeschaltet von der Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung.
Oder wird Ende des Monats, glaube ich, ausgeschaltet.
Das heißt, du musst jetzt für jedes SSH-Login immer Handy entsperren, Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung eingeben. Immer.
Und du kannst ins 2FA-Token nur alle 30 Sekunden neu generieren und es geht nur einmal.
Das heißt, wenn du dich auf 5 Produktionsserver verbinden willst, brauchst du schon mal 2 Minuten 30.
Bis du auf allen Servern drauf bist.
So, und SCP geht nicht mehr.
Ich habe jetzt an ganz vielen Stellen schon gemeckert, dass ich dann in Zukunft nichts mehr von und auf Server drauf kopieren kann.
Und sie sagen an allen Stellen, ja, da können wir nichts dran ändern.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich werde das dann auch so machen.
Wenn irgendjemand sagt, Max, kannst du uns mal kurz einen Log zur Verfügung stellen?
dann sage ich, nee, ich kann nichts mehr vom Server runter kopieren.
Ich glaube, das ist denen noch allen gar nicht klar, was sie da machen wollen.
Zumindest, ich habe schon ein Workaround gefunden.
Ich habe schon ein Workaround gefunden.
Weil hier halt irgendjemand geschrieben hat, Netcat über SSH.
Also ich habe tatsächlich schon versucht, über SSH Netcat aufzumachen, das Standard-In, Standard-Out zu verbinden.
Das klingt nach blindem Sehen.
Ich glaube, das ist wieder die übliche Sache.
Irgendjemand hat irgendwie was angestellt, was aufgefallen ist.
Und deswegen wird es jetzt für alle abgeschaltet.
So, irgendwie sowas in der Richtung habe ich schon probiert.
Aber ich habe dann was viel besseres gefunden.
Kennt ihr SSH Multiplexing?
SSH Multiplexing.
Das hier.
Das funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Wenn du per SSH eine Verbindung aufmachst,
normalerweise wird pro SSH-Aufruf eine Verbindung aufgemacht.
Mit Multiplexing wird einmalig bzw. alle 10 Minuten in dem Fall hier eine Verbindung, eine Master-Connection aufgemacht. Hier dieses Socket-File wird dann angelegt und alle weiteren SSH-Verbindungen benutzen die Master-Verbindung.
das heißt du musst dich nur einmal alle ich das kannst du hier auch einfach auf acht stunden
stellen muss ich nur einmal auf einen server einloggen und dann kannst du dich für die nächsten
acht stunden quasi über die schon bestehende verbindung einloggen und witzigerweise scp
kraft auch darauf zu und scp funktioniert dann ganz ohne login ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das
das ist was sie haben wollen weil sie wollten es ja sicherer machen mit dem workaround hast
halt ein login pro tag das vielleicht nicht mehr das wie sie sich gedacht haben aber es
funktioniert und ich meine es geht immer noch über den proxys wird immer noch aufgezeichnet
also kann sich auch keiner irgendwie beschweren aber ich werde das dann so machen ich werde dann
einfach alle meine ssh verbindung multiplexen und auf jeden server auf dem ich mich eingeloggt
habe brauche ich dann für den jeweiligen arbeitstag hat einfach kein weiteres login
mehr was auch okay und dann muss ich mal gucken vielleicht finde ich wirklich noch
ein trick tatsächlich so wie ihr da schreibt mit erster das zu machen oder so ja
das ist okay das geht ja über den proxy
ja ja zwar faktor authentifizierung auf dem handy
ja das ist so bei uns ist es so in produktion
wenn mich jemand anschreibt von den leuten die die anwendung betreiben auf dem server und sagen
Max, guck mal.
Könntest du mal in Produktion auf Server XY gucken,
was dort im Logverzeichnis liegt oder im Tempverzeichnis liegt oder sowas?
Da muss der mir ein Ticket aufmachen, weil ich kann mich nicht ohne Ticket einloggen.
Also, das stimmt nicht.
Ich kann mich schon ohne Ticket einloggen,
aber danach gibt es eine böse Mail, dass man sich ohne gültigen Grund eingeloggt hat.
Der muss ein Ticket aufmachen.
Du darfst dich nicht in Produktion einloggen ohne gültiges Ticket.
Hast du gelitten.
Und das machen die auch.
Weil die wissen genau, es geht nicht ohne Ticket.
Die machen mittlerweile, ich finde das eigentlich gar nicht schlecht.
Die machen mittlerweile wirklich für jeden Furz ein Ticket auf.
Also,
Disk erweitern,
Dienst neu starten,
Server rebooten,
Logfiles runterziehen,
Logfiles zippen.
Irgendwie
Pseudo-Berechtigung anpassen.
Conjop einrichten. Alles Ticket.
Alles Ticket. Aber ich bin nicht auch okay, ja.
Ja, wenn kurz was zu gucken ist,
es muss ein Ticket.
Logfiles zippen. Muss ein Ticket.
Kurz was gucken.
Kurz gucken, wie die CPU-Auslastung ist.
Wenn dir das nicht reicht, was im Monitoring
steht, Ticket.
Meinst du, die wollen das dann gleich abstellen?
Aber warum? Ich gehe doch immer noch über den Proxy.
Da ist ja wirklich nichts Verwerfliches dran.
Verhindert der Proxy auch gewisse Commands?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Ja, so sieht es aus
Also Chat, seid froh
Wenn ihr nicht so viel Bürokratie bei euch braucht
Aber im
Frankfurter Finanzbranche
Business Enterprise
Da ist das so
damit reguliert und bürokratie ohne ende
Da habe ich immer den Eindruck, da hat keiner Bock, weil dort, egal ob du gute Arbeit leistest oder schlechte Arbeit leistest oder motiviert bist und nicht motiviert bist oder innovativ bist oder nicht,
du eh das gleiche bekommst nach Tarif und Dienstzugehörigkeit.
Da haben die alle keinen Bock, so mein Eindruck.
ja aber ganz ehrlich wenn sich motivation einsatz ahnung erfahrung
know-how wenn sich das nicht lohnt dann macht halt jeder das mindeste was er
machen muss und stresst sie nicht
Ich esse jetzt mal mein Toastbrot, weil erstens wird es kalt, zweitens muss ich in 45 Minuten
auf man muss ja auch mal weg das ist keine so gute idee würde ich sagen
also ganz ehrlich vertrieb ohne profession als der komplett knicken
er muss ja nicht gleich kommen die gruppe schneeball system machen
das mindset mindset aber ohne profession ist das glaube ich echt schwierig mit vertrieb weil ich
muss sich auch lohnen wenn das verkauf bringt ja nichts wenn der gleiche der mit fünf leuten
am tag spricht aber nichts abschließt das gleiche bekommt wieder mit fünf leuten am
tag schließt und viermal abschließen das ist immer so ganz ehrlich macht euch keine gedanken
oder keine Hoffnung, dass es woanders besser ist.
Das Gras sieht von außen immer viel grüner
auf der anderen Seite aus.
Alle Unternehmen haben irgendwelche eigene Arten
und alle haben irgendwelche Dinger,
wo du dir komplett an den Kopf greifst
und man sich denkt so, alter,
kann doch nicht sein, dass es euch überhaupt noch gibt,
wenn ihr das macht.
Nee, habe ich nicht mitgekriegt.
So, lasst uns mal kurz gucken.
Wir gucken uns jetzt mal kurz das Video hier an von FireShip zu Axios.
Mal gucken, was der zu sagen hat.
Und vielleicht gibt es ja noch ein paar neue Erkenntnisse.
Also wie gesagt, meinem Wissen nach war Axios 036 und Axios 114 betroffen.
und wenn man in den letzten paar Tagen
ein npm update oder sowas gemacht hat
und npm install
und
halt diese Version in seiner Package.json
drinstehen hat oder in seinem Package.json
Log heißt das glaube ich, Package.log
drinstehen hat
dann hat man sich höchstwahrscheinlich
irgendeine Malware eingefangen
und das muss ja auch nicht nur auf dem Desktop
oder auf den Entwicklerkisten sein, es kann ja auch
in irgendwelchen CI-CD Workflows sein
Da weiß ich nicht, was die Mailwell macht und wie verwundbar das ist, aber das ist auch durchaus möglich, dass das in irgendeiner Pipeline läuft. Und wenn es in irgendeiner Pipeline läuft und die veröffentlicht quasi Pakete, wäre es ja sogar möglich, dass dort auch wiederum manipulierte Pakete veröffentlicht werden. Also das ist alles nicht so easy. Gucken wir uns mal kurz an, was Fireship dazu sagt.
Ist das laut genug? Warte mal, ich muss mal checken.
Ja, das ist gut, oder?
Sag mal, hat Firechip mittlerweile seine Stimme AI generiert und spricht das gar nicht mehr selbst?
...when making HTTP requests in Node.js in the browser.
But now, that improved developer experience just turned into non-consensual backdoor penetration by a magnum-sized Trojan.
Two different malicious versions of Axios were published to the NPM registry that contained a highly sophisticated supply chain attack that compromises...
Ich hab mich vertan, Leute. Es ist nicht 036 gewesen, es ist 030 und 114.
...of Axios were published to the NPM registry that contained a highly sophisticated supply chain attack that compromises...
E-Mail-Tipps
Ich frage mich, wie sie das wieder hingekriegt haben.
Letztendlich muss ja ein Axios-Maintainer,
wie irgendwelche Talks geleakt haben,
oder irgendwelche Credentials,
oder bei sich sogar irgendein Keylogger-Mailware oder was auch immer eingefangen haben.
Mal gespannt.
Stimmt.
Und sogar Node.js.
Also ich habe letztens tatsächlich was über HTTP-Clients für JavaScript gelesen.
Und da kam raus, Axios ist eigentlich gar nicht mehr der neueste Shit, den man verwenden soll, sondern Kai heißt das, glaube ich.
Das da.
Tiny Elegant
HTTP Client
Based on Fetch. Das ist jetzt
wohl der neueste Scheiß dafür, ja.
Warum man nicht einfach Fetch
verwendet? Keine Ahnung.
Ich hab bisher immer Fetch verwendet.
Weiß das jemand?
Was sind die Vorteile von Axios oder
Kai versus Fetch?
Man kann ganz davon abgesehen, dass du vielleicht 1, 2 Parameter abkürzen kannst oder sowas.
Guck hier, Version 4.20.
Du kannst Fetch-Requests auch abbrechen.
Da gibt's doch irgendwie, Moment mal, in Firefox.
Irgendwie so, Abort-Controller?
Genau, das gibt's.
Damit kannst du Fetch-Anfragen abbrechen.
Das geht.
Und, guck mal, sogar Safari kann das.
Das ist ja immer die Frage bei neueren JavaCrypt-Sachen, dass Safari irgendwas nicht supportet, ja?
Okay, wir wissen also nicht wie.
Okay.
Ich dachte vielleicht, weiß er da ein bisschen mehr, wie sie da Zugriff bekommen haben.
Und obwohl der Code obfusciert wurde, konnte Step Security ihn analysieren.
Der Rattropper arbeitet mit dem Piggybacken auf NPM Install's Lifecycle.
Der Script wird zuerst den System, den du runterleitest, entdecken,
dann zu einem Remote Command & Control Server,
wo es einen zweiten Stage Payload auf dem System für dich anbietet.
Nach dem Downloaden schreibt es den Payload an den Disk,
dann verabschiedet es, um Remote Access zu erzeugen,
an dem Punkt kann es deine Kredite remote steuern und alle anderen schlechten Dinge machen.
Und dann schließt es sich nach sich selbst, um keine Detektion zu vermeiden.
It deletes itself, it deletes the package JSON and removes the post-install script, among other things, so that the end result is running npm audit, it doesn't raise any red flags.
And that's the story of how a single npm install turned your machine into a botnet, which really makes you appreciate rock-solid platforms like Mux, the sponsor of Mux.
Das ist kein Lüge.
Single Board Computer Hobby ist
tot. Naja, es gibt
jetzt einen neuen Raspberry Pi mit
3 GB. Warum mit 3 GB?
Weil der RAM so scheiß teuer ist.
Und die neue 16 GB Variante
oder was heißt die neue? Die abgedatete
16 GB Variante
kostet 100 Euro mehr vom Raspberry Pi.
Früher hast du für
39 Euro oder so einen Raspberry Pi
gekriegt. Lass mal kurz gucken.
Lass mal kurz bei Geizhals gucken.
Raspberry Pi.
Raspberry Pi 3
Findet man den hier irgendwo noch?
So
Okay, der kostet immer noch 40 Euro
Ja, der ist ja gut
Also der ist ja sogar relativ stabil im Preis geblieben, ja
1 GB DDR2 RAM
Ja und?
Für Kleinkram?
Oder wenn du irgendwie über die GPIO Pins was steuern willst
Ist das vollkommen ausreichend?
Ja, das ist old as fuck.
Oh, warte mal. Moment, Moment.
Ist das 32...
Das ist 32-Bit-only, oder?
Gibt's da nicht mittlerweile Probleme?
Gibt es...
Aber das Raspbian...
Gibt es überhaupt das Raspbian?
Gibt es das noch mit 32-Bit?
32-Bit, ja.
Gibt's immer noch.
Ja, dann...
No problem.
Gucken wir nochmal, Geizhals.
Raspberry Pi 3.
So, gucken wir mal, wie viele RAM.
Ob es da vielleicht noch welche mit...
Wobei, der Raspberry Pi 3, den gab es nur mit einem festen...
Den gab es nur mit einem Gig, ne?
Die gab es nicht in unterschiedlichen Ausführungen, der Raspberry Pi noch, oder?
beim 4er gab es auf jeden Fall mehrere RAM
Ausführungen
hier guck mal 4 GB RAM
82 Euro
da ist bestimmt ein bisschen teurer geworden
ja guck mal hier naja
57 Euro
naja das ist schon ein Unterschied
die sind jetzt bei 78 Euro und ursprünglich waren sie mal bei 57
Zwischenzeitlich?
2000? Warum waren die Dinger
2023 mal so krass
teuer? Das war die Geschichte,
wo die nicht genug produziert haben, richtig?
Da war doch was.
Die haben doch mal eine Weile nicht genug
Raspberry Pis produziert.
Das war doch 2023 irgendwann.
Da war das Schweineteuer, das Zeug.
Naja.
also ich muss ehrlich sagen ich finde das hier ist ein ganz guter preis für
den raspberry pi so in dem dreh 57 57 59 so irgendwas weil du brauchst dir für
das bei passen der sd karte am besten am besten sogar eine ssd je nachdem was du
also micro sd karten kann ich wenn überhaupt nur die die samsung endurance
dinge empfehlen ja das video habe ich gesehen der
vorschau, deswegen laber ich da gerade ein bisschen drüber.
Mal gucken, was er in dem Video sagt.
Dann brauchst du ja noch
ein Netzteil.
Da tut es aber halt auch
eins, was man schon hat.
Ja, aber so ein Raspberry Pi
alleine ist meistens
nicht genug. Man braucht immer ein bisschen was dabei.
Und man
ist selten mit diesen 54, 57,
59 Euro alleine.
Fertig.
Jeder war preislich.
ja noch, aber
mittlerweile werden die Dinge halt brutal teuer.
Gerade die mit mehr RAM.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Twitch User.
Das ist Spam, oder?
Ist das Werbung?
Ist das verkappte Werbung hier?
Promotion?
Bei dem Username?
Nein, du hast mal drauf reagiert
vor fünf Jahren? Was?
Wie heißen die?
Ich kann mich da überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Stellenanzeige.
Ah, so.
Ich kann mich dunkel dran erinnern.
Habe ich die geflamed oder fand ich die gut?
Ich kann mich aber dunkel dran erinnern.
Ganz, ganz, ja, ja.
War das die PHP Magier?
Oder sowas?
Ich kann mich dunkel dran erinnern
Aber
So genau weiß ich das auch nicht mehr
Raspberry Pi Zero 2
Zero W 2 ist es da oder?
Mit WLAN
Oder heißen die mittlerweile nur so
Davon habe ich auch noch welche.
Wir gucken uns mal das Video von ihm an.
6 Minuten 32 können wir uns sehr easy angucken.
Mal gucken, was er dazu sagt.
Von dem gucke ich die Videos übrigens ganz gerne.
Nicht unbedingt jedes.
Aber der macht immer ganz interessante Videos.
Airwire.
Keck.
Wait.
Ja, genau, das habe ich auch gelesen.
3 GB Raspberry Pi Model für 3,80 Dollar.
Was ich witzig finde, wenn man das jetzt mal vergleicht mit dem hier,
guck mal, das ist das 4 GB Model.
Das gibt es aktuell noch hier für 87 Euro.
Also noch ist das ganz okay.
Boah, also 299 ist einfach lächerlich für einen Raspberry Pi.
Dafür kriegst du ja schon komplette Mini-PCs.
Okay, auch nicht mit 16 GB, ja?
Oder wahrscheinlich auch mit 16 GB?
Vielleicht kriegst du davon schon richtige Mini-PCs mit 16 GB.
Ich muss halt sagen, wenn du den Raspberry Pi für hauptsächlich, sagen wir mal, Compute verwendest,
also im Endeffekt, wenn du da Container drauflaufen lässt,
Compute ist vielleicht der falsche Ausdruck,
Ja, wenn du das Ding einfach nur als Linux-Server verwendest, drücken wir es mal so aus, da kann man sich auch ein x86 Mini-PC kaufen. Ich glaube, das ist preis-leistungsmäßig in ähnlichen Kategorien, in ähnlichen Sphären wie mittlerweile Raspberry Pi, also die günstigen.
So, wenn man den Raspberry Pi aber braucht, als Bastelplattform, wenn man die GPIOs verwenden will, dann braucht man ja aber auch keine 16 GB.
Aber es ist trotzdem lächerlich teuer.
Die sind nur so teuer wegen den RAM-Preisen, ja.
Es war bereits ziemlich hochpreisig, als es entstanden ist.
Und das Problem ist, dass alle RAM, alle DRAM...
5 im stream hatten oder nicht
ich kriege ich dann raus was für ein raspberry pi das ist bei info oder so
was
c
cpu info
How to find which Pi I am using.
Okay, Cat Model.
Bam.
Raspberry Pi 4 Model B Ref 1.5.
Okay, kein 5er.
Weil du brauchst ja da auch noch einen Kühler dabei.
Du brauchst vielleicht noch einen Case dabei.
Einen Netzteil dabei.
Eine SSD eventuell dabei.
oder zumindest eine Samsung Endurance Micro SD.
Da kommt ja schon einiges dabei noch.
Das ist der RAM, der so teuer ist.
Und, äh, du weißt, was die Probleme sind, die diese Schwierigkeit verursachen, ob es
AI-Vorgaben sind, die nicht tatsächlich materialisieren, äh, Leute lügen über die Menge
von DRAM, die sie brauchen und reservieren von Foundries, ob es eine Verlust oder
was auch immer äh von den DRAM-Firmen, die diese Dinge vermitteln.
Ich weiß nicht. Das eine, was ich weiß, ist, dass all diese Dinge
zusammenhelfen, um, glaube ich, eine Menge von Dingen zu töten, die Leute
was Leute gerne machen würden, wie SBCs kaufen und Spaß-Projekte mit ihnen machen.
Wenn die Firma, von der du dein SBC kaufst, nicht bereits betroffen ist, dann wird sie das
und ich wette, dass sie es schon sind, aber einige Leute haben bereits den Preis eingepasst,
andere haben es noch nicht und haben eine alte Stärke, die sie noch versuchen zu verlassen.
Aber wenn man mit anderen Firmen spricht, die SBCs machen, außer Raspberry Pi,
projects that have been completely canceled because they can't get memory
like the 16 gig pie 5 there's not many people that are gonna pay 300 bucks for
one of these i only have one and that's because it was already a dubious value
at 120 bucks when i bought it at 300 bucks there's no reason to buy this
unless you have like a product that last mal gerade lassen zwar gerade gucken
Was kosten hier das?
8 Gig
16 Gig
217 haben wir gerade.
Das ist jetzt schon arschteuer.
Ja, guckt hier.
Das waren wir bei 120.
Und das kam mir auch schon teuer vor.
Das würde sich sehr tief in die Karte legen, wenn der Preis von 150% des Komponenten erhöht wird.
Aber es ist einfach verrückt. Ich habe hier einige Charts zusammengelegt.
Dieses Datakit finde ich meistens Schrott. Das Case, was bei den Datakits dabei ist, ist meistens Schrott.
Wenn die Klöcker-Samsung offizielles Netzteil, die SD-Karten, die dabei sind, sind meistens Schrott.
Diese Datakits gefallen mir nicht.
Das ist schon teuer geworden.
Das gibt's.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es 1.5 Gig Chips überhaupt gibt.
Was für ein Ding! Von dem habe ich noch nie was gehört.
Ich finde es irgendwie cool, dass viele das Raspberry Pi Layout, zumindest dort, wo die GPIO-Pins sind, uns in diesen Formfaktor geklaut haben. Das finde ich mega nice, weil da kannst du oftmals Zubehör für ein Pi verwenden.
Okay, Max, was ist das?
Ich trau mich jetzt mal das anzuklicken, okay?
Was ist das?
Getting into my wife's furry...
Moment, der Lockpicking-Lawyer
Okay, weil du's bist
Aber erstmal gucken wir das hier fertig
...and haben Zeit, ein volles Video darauf zu machen
Das ist wahrscheinlich der beste
value sbc you can get right now and uses a qualcomm chip on it the rock 5c is also a good
value but i've seen it going out of stock a lot other than that i've tested the orange pi 5 and pi
5 pro those are both very good boards but those are going up in price even more than the pi so
it's like those were great values but now it's 2026 and that's just not a thing if i look at
the 8 gig ram models again the q6a right now if you can get it that is the best value sbc you can
Ja, hätte ich jetzt eigentlich auch gedacht.
Es kommt mit einem Case und all dem.
Du musst nichts extra kaufen.
Es war früher ein guter Wert, als die meisten SBCs.
Aber jetzt sind sie einfach auf der gleichen Ebene.
Aber die 16 GB Pi5, das ist einfach...
Ich weiß nicht, wer eines dieser Sachen kaufen wird.
Es ist eine verrückte Menge Geld, um für einen SBC zu bezahlen.
Mit der Leistung, die es hat und den Features, die es hat.
Es gab einen Widerstand gegen Raspberry Pi für diese Sachen.
Ich finde das witzig, dass im Jahr 2026 jetzt ernsthaft wieder der Raspberry Pi 3 interessant wird.
Das hat man auch nicht gedacht, oder?
Das stimmt.
Aber ja, Vorteile.
a full Linux install, now you can do it in
MicroPython almost just as easy
or building smart home things.
Wenn du dich quälen willst, kannst du auch in C++ machen.
Ich bin der Meinung, in C++, Microcontroller
in C++ ist immer noch das
das Beste, auch wenn es
C++ ist. Weder
Lua noch MicroPython noch sonst was
C++, gerade wenn man Zugriff
auf die ganzen Libraries will oder das
SDK vom Hersteller verwenden will,
dann kommst du halt an C++ nicht vorbei, auch wenn
ich jedes Mal kotzen muss.
Bei jeder Zeile C++, aber
gerade für ESP32 ist das immer noch
das Beste.
Wann wieder Bastelstream?
Würde ich sofort
machen, wenn ich ein gutes Projekt hätte.
Mir fällt gerade kein gutes
Projekt ein, wo ich Bock drauf hätte
und oder was ich brauche.
Even if we're talking about buying used hardware, the prices on that stuff is going up, especially if it has a lot of RAM.
So certain hobbies are just kind of impacted and dying off right now.
I don't see a rosy future for it, unless we can find a way to get these prices back down at some point.
Because my income from YouTube hasn't gone up. In fact, it's gone down a little bit the past year and a half.
because YouTubes Viewer...
Achso, Oktober bis Dezember,
wollte ich gerade sagen, für einen Monat, ist ja richtig krass.
Aber...
... für long form videos like these
has gone down.
And yeah, it's not a great
situation that we're in for this.
Gut.
Es ist ja nicht abzusehen, wann die Preise wieder runter
gehen.
Also,
ich denke mal, wir sind,
wenn wir nicht super viel
Kohle ausgeben wollen, noch eine
Weile quasi stuck
mit der Hardware, die wir schon gerade haben.
Okay, weil es da Max
gepostet hat, gucken wir mal.
Der April-Scherz vom Lockpicking-Lawyer.
Okay, ich habe schon richtig lang
keinen Lockpicking-Lawyer mehr geguckt.
Was war das, was er immer
gesagt hat? Der hat doch so einen Spruch gehabt,
den er immer gebracht hat.
Kein Spruch.
Ach genau, wo er
dann immer erzählt hat,
3 is binding.
Wenn er die Dinger geknackt hat.
Okay, off it.
Warum geht er das Lockpicken los?
Das Gefühl habe ich auch, brav am Maik.
Ich habe noch nicht das Inneres von vielen Frauen-Fanys gesehen, aber mein Verständnis.
880 xd
Aha, okay ram
Warum hast du zwei grafikkarten oder ist das entweder oder
die habe ich auch das ist ein wasser ja doch das wasserkühlung irgendwas in der
richtung habe ich auch von von arctic cooling das ist entweder oder
das habe ich glaube auch
Oh ja
Hast du keine
Festplatte mehr drin, wenn du ein bisschen mehr brauchst
Als ein T
Oder hast du noch alte
Mit der
Mainboard
Nee, hast du hier
Gehäuse fehlt noch, oder
Was für ein Gehäuse hast du
Oder hast du dein altes Gehäuse noch verwendet
Wie viel RAM hat denn eigentlich jemand in Raspberry Pi, wo wir gerade dabei sind?
Green.
Acht. Boah.
Der wäre jetzt richtig teuer mittlerweile.
8 GB Pi 4.
Ich hab noch ein Pi 2
irgendwo rumfliegen.
Gibt es dafür überhaupt noch aktuelle...
Gibt es noch...
Gibt es noch aktuelles Raspberry Pi OS
für den Pi 2?
Okay, man kann immer noch Raspberry Pi OS drauf machen anscheinend.
Weil das ist ja glaube ich sogar noch die ganz alte ARM Architektur der Pi 2.
Also einen Pi 1 habe ich tatsächlich nicht.
Hat noch einer von euch einen Raspberry Pi 1 rumfliegen?
Das ist das Ding, was noch ein S-Video Output hatte.
Ich glaube, das kannst du heute wirklich in die Tonne kloppen, Pie1.
Ich soll mal meinen Tee trinken.
Und ich muss mal kurz auf mein Handy gucken.
Nicht, dass mich versucht, jemand in der Bereitschaft zu erreichen und ich bin nicht da.
Hallo Max, hast du das Ticket in Int und Prot schon umgesetzt?
Äh.
Welches Ticket?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Das Ticket.
Es gibt nur eins.
Nee, keine Ahnung.
Weiß ich nicht, was gemeint ist.
ich
dort die Tränen
die Leute
in der 20 Minuten bin ich noch da
jetzt sehen was
was euch so auf denen auf der Wiener Spur das sehr unter den Fingern Prozent
in den fingern juckt oder irgendwie unter den
Den nägeln brennt sagt man
Das team ist nicht
Stream wäre nur nur der wenn mich jetzt jemand anruft
und sagt max produktionsausfall dann würde ich tatsächlich hier ins sind ausloggen mich auf der arbeit einloggen
und
erstmal zweieinhalb Minuten warten, bis ich mich auf
allen Brottkisten von dem Service verbunden habe.
Wegen Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung.
Du hast dir
ein Neo-WIM aufgesetzt. Exzellent.
Hast du alles komplett
selbst konfiguriert oder hast du
irgendwie eine dieser
super bloated
WIM-Configs
von GitHub genommen? Also ich bin ja
Fan von selbst konfigurieren.
Müsstest du nicht erst noch die Ticketnummer nachschauen?
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, welches Ticket es geht.
Ach so meinst du das?
Du meinst für...
Naja, wenn es Produktionsausfälle gibt,
dann gibt es meistens schon automatisch erstelltes Incident-Ticket,
mit dem du dich einloggen kannst.
Wenn nicht, müsste ich theoretisch eins erstellen.
Ich kann mir auch selbst ein Ticket erstellen.
Lieber Neo-Wim oder normales Wim?
Ganz ehrlich, nachdem ich mein Neo-Wim nicht super krass aufgemotzt habe,
oder keinen Anwendungszweck für super aufgemotztes Wim habe,
benutze ich immer noch Standard-Wim.
Kein Neo-Wim.
Ich mache das auch hauptsächlich aus dem Grund,
weil Wim auf jedem Server drauf ist
und ich mich nicht an irgendwelches Zeug gewöhnen will,
was nicht im normalen Wim auf meinen Kisten drauf ist.
Aber wie gesagt, meine Wim-Config, da steht ja auch so gut wie nichts drin, ja?
Das sind irgendwie hier 43 Zeilen Wim-Config und das meiste davon brauchst du wahrscheinlich heute mal.
Outlook ist bei uns auch so heftig langsam.
Also das ist, das ist, ich hasse Outlook.
Also ich meine, ich mag das ganze Office-Zeug nicht und ich benutze das ganze Office-Zeug auch nicht.
Das Einzige, was ich ab und zu mal verwende, ist PowerPoint oder so.
Wenn ich mal irgendwas zeigen will, weil die halt alle auf PowerPoint-Präsentationen stehen.
Aber ganz ehrlich, Outlook ist so ein Rotz.
Du scrollst und es hängt einfach für 30 Sekunden unerklärlich.
Also das ist der größte Shit überhaupt.
Genau, genau, das mache ich nicht.
Wie gesagt, ich benutze Vim täglich.
Also, auf Servern nur, nix anderes.
Ich benutze kein Nano oder irgendwie sowas.
Ich bin Wim-only.
Und ich benutze Wim auch bei mir hier lokal auf dem Rechner.
Immer halt für so kleine Edit-Sachen.
Ja, wenn ich hier sage, ZSH editieren.
Für größere Sachen, für Frontend-Projekte oder sowas.
Dann mache ich natürlich hier Wishlist Studio Code
oder irgendein IntelliJ, äh, nee, nicht IntelliJ,
JetBrains IDE auf.
Cache-Mode deaktivieren, dann läuft's.
Bezieht sich auf was?
Du meinst bei Outlook?
Ja gut, das kann ich nicht ändern.
Wir kriegen ja Outlook
voll installiert auf so einer Windows-Kiste.
Da logge ich mich drauf ein.
Witzigerweise per Shitrix.
Und dann ist das halt so.
Ich will da auch nichts dran rumkonfigurieren.
Wenn die schon sagen, ey, wir stellen euch das zur Verfügung,
dann sollen sie auch gucken, dass es funktioniert.
der film tutor das ist gar nicht übel wobei ich wahrscheinlich die meisten
sachen aus dem tutor auch gar nicht hinkriegen würde
das sind wahrscheinlich schon ein bisschen etwas andere sachen dabei also
ich weiß was ganz ehrlich was braucht was brauchst du hoch runter hier gg mal
ab und zu Visual Select, um irgendwas
zu copy-pasten oder zu löschen.
Ähm.
Ans Ende der Zeile mit Insert.
Zeile löschen.
Ähm.
Hier innerhalb der Klammern.
Ja.
Ich bin auch niemand, der mit
J, K, L und so navigiert.
Ich navigiere tatsächlich
immer noch mit Pfeiltasten.
das war es zum größten teil
also wenn magic dich ach so ja und was was wird also es gibt eine sache die ich mega
nice in dem finde überlegt euch mal ich kopiere das hier ja da kopiere ich jetzt
an zeilnummern mit ansonsten müsste ich hier set no number machen zum kopieren
blickt euch das mache ich in wim auf set pace zack und jetzt habe ich den mist
Guck mal, jetzt kann man anstatt so hier so komisch rumselecten, kann man einfach drücken Shift-V, ne, äh, Ctrl-V.
Und jetzt kann man hier quasi vertikal selecten. Seht ihr das?
Vertikal selecten und wegmachen.
Und wenn ich alles auskommentieren will, kann ich auch sagen, vertikal selecten, groß I, auskommentieren, escape, alles auskommentiert.
Also Wim hat schon ein paar ganz coole Sachen.
Oder was auch nice ist, stelle ich mir mal vor, hier, und hier ist jetzt hier irgendwas innerhalb, ich setze hier eine Variable, gleich, sowieso.
Und wenn ihr jetzt alles, alles ändern wollt, was in den Anführungszeichen steht, ne, drückt ihr CI Anführungszeichen und dann könnt ihr direkt, also CI, Change, Inner und dann das Surrounding Ding.
Geht aber Klammern auch.
Also Wim ist schon nice.
Aber ich bin auch weit davon entfernt, die super advanced Sachen in Wim zu machen.
Ich bin auch weg von Relative Line Numbers
Und sowas, dass die Line Numbers dann
Es gibt ja hier
Set Rel oder wie war das? Relative Numbers
Guck, dann siehst du hier immer
Die Zeilen oben und unten
Da kannst du für WIM-Kommandos
Kannst du die verwenden, ja
Wenn die Zeilen
Siehst du immer wie viel Offset quasi
Nach oben und unten
Find ich auch eher nervig als nice
Wenn du das satisfying findest
Es gibt ein paar Wim-Videos auf YouTube
Da sind die richtig hardcore Wim-Hackermans
Am Start
Wen ich auch krass finde
Was Wim angeht
Ist dieser
Moment, Moment, Moment
Competitive
Programming
Ich glaube, der Dude ist das hier.
Also wenn er in Wim tippt,
ja,
der ist echt abgedreht,
der Dude, ja, also das...
Guck, der macht das auch in Wim, siehste?
Und es ist Wim...
Das Krasse ist bei dem Dude, ihr seht es hier,
der benutzt Wim unter Windows,
Geh Wim unter Windows
und macht da drinnen C++ ohne.
Und jetzt könnt ihr ohne jegliches Auto complete oder sonst was.
Der weiß es einfach komplett auswendig.
Der kennt die komplette C++-Standard-Library auswendig.
Das müsst ihr euch vorstellen.
Also eines der unintuitivsten Dinger schlechthin macht der einfach.
und in welchem Tempo der da
Dinger zusammenbastelt, ist echt nicht mehr feierlich.
Also der ist krass, der Typ.
Ich meine,
schön sieht das Source-Code immer nicht aus
bei Competitive Programming.
Es muss funktionieren und es muss schnell laufen.
guck mal die die die c++ fanboys die werden sagen using namespace std soll man nicht machen
aber dem kommt auf jeden buchstaben an aber der kerl ist wirklich heftig hier der hat es drauf
Excel Compatibility
Das habe ich auch mal geguckt
Da gibt es doch sogar
Excel
Warte mal
Excel World Championship
Excel Esports
Ja
Und das geile ist
Also
Das wird ja sogar kommentiert.
Das hört sich an wie irgendeine CS-Veranstaltung.
Das ist wirklich mit Commentary dabei.
Excel World Championships.
Ja, Axel, es gibt nichts, was es nicht gibt.
Das ist Eve Online.
Ja.
Eve Online muss auch viel Axel-Geschubse sein, ja.
ist überhaupt nicht mein game ich mag keine science fiction also
weniger mag nicht so sehr science fiction games und das ist das ist sogar
mir zu hardcore für mmo
Naja, ganz im Ernst, Leute.
Die Hardcore Path of Exile Trader,
für die wird das auch mehr oder weniger
nur eine Excel-Tabelle sein.
Oder
viel Excel-Tabellen.
Geschubse.
Nicht schlecht, das heißt du bist da voll drin oder was?
6 Stunden EVE Online, krass.
Nee, das ist YouTube, was wieder rumspackt.
Also ich kann mich noch erinnern, zu Zeiten, wo ich noch MMOs gespielt hab,
da hat EVE Online mal Schlagzeilen gemacht,
weil sie dort irgendeine, boah, ich krieg's nicht richtig zusammen,
irgendeinen Gildenleiter social engineered haben.
Da hat sich irgendeiner als E-Girl ausgegeben, den Begriff gab es ja damals noch nicht, und hat sich an den Gildenleiter rangemacht und hat so darüber irgendwie Zugriff auf dem sein Account bekommen und dann irgendwie alles gelöscht oder so.
Das war sogar in Mainstream-Medien damals.
Moin.
So, Chat.
Schön, dass ihr da wart.
Ich muss jetzt leider auf.
Morgen dann wieder streamen mit etwas Inhalt.
Mal gucken, was wir dann machen.
Trunas machen wir wahrscheinlich morgen, würde ich sagen, oder?
Wird mal Zeit, Trunas anzugucken.
dass ich dann endgültig
mal auf
Grundlage
aktueller Erfahrung mit
Schunas sagen kann, dass ich es nicht mag
ich gehe nämlich davon aus, mir wird es nicht gefallen, weil das letzte Mal
hat es mir auch überhaupt nicht gefallen, aber mal gucken
vielleicht überrascht es mich
ja, ab wann bin ich mir nicht ganz
sicher, das hängt ein bisschen davon ab, wie das
Wetter morgen wird, wenn das Wetter gut ist
will ich mein Fahrrad mal wieder einweihen
für dieses Jahr, ich bin ja dieses Jahr noch gar nicht gefahren
und da bin ich dann wahrscheinlich
zwei, drei Stunden unterwegs.
Und dann wahrscheinlich erst am Nachmittag.
Mal gucken.
Das Wetter weht gut.
Gestern geguckt, in Frankfurt wird das gar nicht so dolle,
glaube ich. Es ist ziemlich bewölkt morgen.
Alles klar. Chat,
schön, dass ihr dabei wart.
freut mich immer zu sehen,
dass so viele am Start sind.
Wem es gefallen hat,
wer das nächste Mal wieder mit dabei sein will,
kann mir einen Follow dalassen.
Und wir sehen uns
im nächsten Stream.
Bis dann. Macht's gut.
See you.